I love the Buddha check it out people
they're talking I'm wondering does buns
have the cardio bonds has cargo they
want to wonder if buns can duck and move
busca ducking move don't watch out too
fast for you to even see because he
keeps pushing and stuff like that
check it people wonder how is he's so
powerful because of the training because
I never stopped with the pushing all the
time
buns is here appreciates any challenges
from anybody who wants to step into the
ring for a sparring session and deliver
pleasure back to them so at any time if
any NorCal folks that are saying or
crazy you want to get up with it holler
at me man you know where to find me
anytime
I appreciate you all loves everybody all
over the world